well let's get the latest on the
situation on the ground with retired Air
Vice Marshal Sean belshawn thanks a lot
for being here so what is the latest
despite the fact that spring arrived
yesterday there's been heavy snowing
back moot over the last few days uh we
had some video footage of from a few
days ago but um eight months of
intensive fighting
um so you can see the video footage here
um actually the levels of Russian
attacks have fallen by they're down to
about 25 to the level they they once
were the video shows the Wagner group
getting very close to the center to the
uh City admin building they're about 400
meters away from that that's been
geolocated but if we move out to the
maps the little red icon is actually
Where the wild group have got to that
the um the Russians are pushing into the
center but the ukrainians are still
holding ground and actually protecting
their resupply routes but it does seem
to have got a bit stagnant but if we
look wider though this fight isn't just
fighting here is 1200 kilometers of
front line and all the way along there's
fighting good two good examples there
just south of back moot the Russians
have been trying to encircle that for
the last few months um almost certainly
stalled and down to the South Marine
curve the Russians have been trying to
seize that since the start of the war
for 14 months in they've made an advance
of two kilometers just shows how
difficult the fighting is along the
whole front line why are the Russians
struggling so much 80 days into this
conflict the Russian offensive was
designed to seize the donbass by the
31st of March they've thrown 300 000
soldiers at it they've devastated the
city and yet they seem to run out of
steam now for a military perspective
you'd pause
but they've not they've just got
themselves wrapped in a rolling sort of
grinding War of Attrition Ukraine is one
of the reasons its historical defense
one of the Region's poor Russian tactics
mod said the other day it was 200 000
Russian casualties and also they've done
it in winter Russians should not have
attacked it winter it does restrict your
options so why don't they pause and
regroup the Russians following a series
of military failures Putin put grazimov
in charge who runs the Russian army he
organized and led the invasion of Crimea
but he's failed to make a difference
here and frankly he's bound to political
pressure now just to make whatever
progress they can make
um what's uh I think what's going to
happen is that all he should be doing
from military perspective is eroding
um you know preserving his combat power
ready for the Ukrainian offense in fact
what he's doing is just wasting it and
the danger is that whatever happens
there's going to be a few military heads
roll I have no doubt but that's not
going to solve the systemic problem
within the Russian military